Today, Joe Biden and Donald Trump both visited the state of New York,
but for two very different reasons.
Joe Biden,
along with former presidents Barack Obama and noted respector of women
Bill Clinton. Yeah,
that whole me too thing really worked out.
Are doing a fundraiser tonight in Manhattan.
Guest list includes Stephen Colbert,
Queen Latifah Lizzo, and Ben Platt.
It cost $255 to attend,
and for 100,000, you can take a picture with them.
They also went on a podcast with a bunch of actors.
Donald Trump, meanwhile,
attended the funeral of slain NYPD officer Jonathan Diller.
Officer Diller was murdered at a routine traffic stop
by a guy with 21 prior arrests.
You know, you think it'd be easy to create a society
where somebody with 21 prior arrests
isn't roaming the street to kill police officers,
but you would apparently be wrong.
He left behind a wife and one year old son.
not only did President Trump attend his funeral in Massapequa today,
but he also reportedly made a large donation to tunnel for towers,
which announced that they would be paying
the mortgage of Officer Dealer's family.
If you wanted to draw a contrast between two candidates for president,
I can't think of a bigger one than this.
One went to raise money with a bunch of rich celebrities.
One attended the funeral of a fallen hero.
The difference seems pretty clear.